Translator: Joseph Geni
Reviewer: Morton Bast
When I was 14 years old,
I had low self-esteem.
I felt I was not talented at anything.
One day, I bought a yo-yo.
When I tried my first trick,
it looked like this:
(Laughter)
I couldn't even do the simplest trick,
but it was very natural for me,
because I was not dextrous,
and hated all sports.
But after one week of practicing,
my throws became more like this:
A bit better.
I thought, the yo-yo
is something for me to be good at.
For the first time in my life,
I found my passion.
I was spending all my time practicing.
It took me hours and hours a day
to build my skills up to the next level.
And then, four years later,
when I was 18 years old,
I was standing onstage
at the World YoYo Contest.
And I won.
I was so excited.
"Yes, I did it! I became a hero.
I may get many sponsors, a lot of money,
tons of interviews,
and be on TV!" I thought.
(Laughter)
But after coming back to Japan,
totally nothing changed in my life.
(Laughter)
I realized society
didn't value my passion.
So I went back to my college
and became a typical Japanese worker
as a systems engineer.
I felt my passion,
heart and soul, had left my body.
I felt I was not alive anymore.
So I started to consider what I should do,
and I thought, I wanted to make
my performance better,
and to show onstage
how spectacular the yo-yo could be
to change the public's image of the yo-yo.
So I quit my company
and started a career
as a professional performer.
I started to learn classic ballet,
jazz dance, acrobatics and other things
to make my performance better.
As a result of these efforts,
and the help of many others,
it happened.
I won the World YoYo Contest again
in the artistic performance division.
I passed an audition for Cirque Du Soleil.
Today, I am standing on the TED stage
with the yo-yo in front of you.
(Applause)
What I learned from the yo-yo is,
if I make enough effort with huge passion,
there is no impossible.
Could you let me share my passion with you
through my performance?
(Applause)
(Water sound)
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
(Music)
(Applause)